. So we're going to separately discuss this
bizarre outburst that Donald Trump had on
Twitter over the weekend.
But here, I want to focus in specifically
on the absolutely massive cyberattack believed
to have been perpetrated by Russia on the
United States.
We've now learned of a massive and ongoing
long term cyber hack by Russia, with evidence
mounting more and more that points to Russia.
Now, of course, you can always say we can
never believe anything we're told about who
did it.
But in that case, you also couldn't believe
the things that Trump says or what anybody
says.
So that's sort of a nonstarter argument if
we want to really evaluate this on on its
merits.
But the details as we know them right now
are that five major federal agencies were
breached according to multiple intelligence
agencies.
It's abundantly clear that it was Russia that
did it.
Now, multiple intelligence agencies drafted
a statement saying Russia did this and the
White House blocked the release of that statement.
According to a senior administration official,
Donald Trump, Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
even appeared on right wing radio show on
the right wing radio show hosted by Mark Levin
and said, quote, We can say pretty clearly
that it was the Russians that engaged in this
activity.
Pompeo didn't get super specific, but U.S.
officials have said privately it was the Foreign
Intelligence Service, the SVR of Russia.
That's what sort of replaced the KGB.
No one is suggesting China played a role.
They believe it was Russia, but not hugely
controversial.
But Donald Trump goes on Twitter and contradicts
his own secretary of State Pompeo, as well
as all intelligence agencies and says, you
know, it could have.
In China, who did it, something for which
we have no evidence whatsoever.
Donald Trump tweeting, quote, This cyber hack
is far greater in the fake news media than
in actuality.
I have been fully briefed and everything is
well under control.
Russia, Russia, Russia is the priority chant
when anything happens, because lame stream
is, for mostly financial reasons, petrified
of discussing the possibility that it may
be China.
It may no evidence of that.
Remember, there could also have been a hit
on our ridiculous voting machines during the
election, which is now obvious that I won
big.
That's not true, making it an even more corrupted
embarrassment for the USA.
So there are so many elements to focus on
here.
Number one, obviously, Donald Trump is not
going to hold Russia accountable in his last
month left in office.
That's completely clear.
But he's also adding without evidence that
the hack even including included more stuff
like voting machines during the election.
So it's considered the stunning nature of
what he's saying.
Trump is distorting what has taken place,
downplaying it and saying the fake news is
blowing it out of proportion, but then adding
that there were actually even more things
hacked than what the fake news media is telling
you, raising this idea that voting machines
were hacked, which is completely self-serving
merely to support his bogus voter voter fraud
theory.
So at the same time, he says this wasn't really
a big deal, but voting machines were also
hacked, which nobody is mentioning, which
sort of makes it sound like it's an even bigger
deal than what is being reported, because
nobody's reporting that voting machines were
hacked because there's no evidence of it.
And then at the same time, sort of like as
the cherry on top floating that it might be
China when nobody thinks it was China and
there's no evidence that it was China.
Now, you don't have to be in favor of attacking
Russia, neither as a left winger or a right
winger to merely acknowledge there's really
no reason to doubt that Russia did this and
to concede that there's no reason to think
China did do it because we don't have any
evidence that China did anything.
So this is a few different things together.
First, this is another example of Trump opting
out of even a mild rebuke of Russia.
That's common.
We've seen that this entire presidency.
Second, this is Donald Trump trying to make
anything that is out there in the news to
be evidence that the election was stolen from
him when he simply lost plain and simple.
And then number three, this is Trump again,
trying to criticize China even when they've
not actually done the thing he's talking about
and forth.
Of course, it's Donald Trump focusing on entirely
the wrong things.
As usual, the response should be, number one,
how do we deal with this thing that Russia
did?
And number two, as the president, he should
be talking about the fact that more than 3000
people are now dying every day from coronavirus
and he's not come out and talked about it.
He seems done with coronavirus.
And number three, Trump still hasn't conceded,
and that's globally shameful as well.
So Trump silent on how to deal with Russia,
silent on three thousand coronavirus deaths
today, silent on conceding this election,
but very loudly suggesting maybe China actually
did this hack.
It's pathetic.
It's dangerous.
It's a national security threat.
And it is now an emergency to get this guy
out.
And that's coming.
We are 30 days away, 30 days away from Donald
Trump being gone.
And that's something that's not just good
for the country, that's very good
for
the world.